alex is with us in Texas hi Alex welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show how are you
better than I deserve what's up I'm
calling because I already had a car you
know that it was paid off learning but
it was getting kind of old and I wanted
to get on your vehicle so I purchased a
2015 Ford Fiesta but right now I've
already had like a year with the loan
and I'm trying to resell it but there
the value is super low yeah I was a
mistake wasn't yes and then I also went
to car mags and the value they're giving
me is probably like four thousand five
hundred yeah well car X is offering you
a wholesale deal because they're gonna
turn on resell the car for a profit so
what you need to do is go to KBB Kelley
Blue Book calm and look at what the
private sale is so they offered you
$4,500 at Carmack's yes and what do you
owe on the car right now it's ten
thousand four hundred and seventeen so
then I would you have to pay your own
5800 yeah well you don't you don't
because you're not gonna do that deal
okay but if you did a private sale on
this car it'll probably bring seven
thousand maybe you just put that with an
individual now what is your income my
income thrown twenty-five thousand I
don't buy the girl what you do for a
living I'm a teacher not a tree you're a
teacher can't read teacher's aide okay
yes you're single how many children do
you have no children
good good okay I'm trying to get out of
this loan you know because I'm trying to
save money for maybe your house yeah you
need to get the loan paid off so here's
what I would do if you made an extra
$800 a month working an extra job or
three
and put all of $800 a month towards this
car you would pay it off in one year and
by next Christmas the car would be yours
and it's paid for and that's what I'm
gonna recommend as you're stuck and
selling it and being six thousand
dollars and dad or five thousand dollars
or four thousand dollars in debt it's
not gonna fix your situation you're
going to increase your income and dump
it all on this card debt and clear as
fast as you can kiddo and never borrow
money to buy a car again the rest of
your life